notre science n'a rien d'habituel dans
les faits rien n'est plus habituel dans
la vie de notre département depuis
plusieurs semaines c'est avec courage
que nous devront accompagner et
construire la prime j'invite chacun et
chacune deux bouts là où il se trouve
avec tout son coeur et sa compassion à
observer une minute de silence à la
mémoire de toutes les victimes de
l'épidémie et en solidarité avec leurs
proches chance
j'aimerais également que nous
applaudissions que nous a prédit sion
tous ces héros du quotidien qu'ils font
l'honneur et la fierté de l'alsace les
personnels soignants les personnels des
ehpad et des services dell à domicile
les agents du service public les
pompiers les policiers et les militaires
les salariés des supermarchés les
artisans les commerçants les routiers
les entreprises solidaires et mobiliser
les associations les citoyens et tant
d'autres que je n'ai pas cité voilà des
années que nous parlions tous dans le
discours de l'humanisme de l'humanisme
alsacien et de l'humanisme rhénan cette
alsace solidaire vibrante et
bouleversante qui a pris les choses en
main dès les premières heures est bien
une réalité à travers ses héros elle le
démontre tous les jours depuis plusieurs
semaines alors chers collègues applaudit
son lait en guise de remerciement dès le
début de cette crise sanitaire sans
précédent et tout particulièrement plus
fort de la vague devions d'être présents
aux côtés de nos concitoyens et de ceux
qui les soignent qui les protègent et
qui les accompagnent au quotidien
présent chers collègues nous l'avons été
et une bleue seront encore jusqu'au bout
de la crise pas seulement parce que le
mot solidarité est inscrit en tête de
nos compétences et que nous mettons un
point d'honneur à les exercer en toute
circonstance mais aussi et surtout parce
que l'esprit de solidarité est
profondément profondément grave
dans notre adn humaniste et que nos
politiques s'inspire bien de cette
phrase du grand albert schweitzer
celui à qui la souffrance est épargné
doit se sentira que les a soulagés celle
des autres ce qui le retient surtout à
coeur de partager avec vous au cours de
ce rapide propos introductif chers
collègues
c'est cette conviction profonde est
aujourd'hui encore renforcé qui ne peut
y avoir de véritable solidarité au sens
que plus large de ce terme qu'avec une
réelle proximité et on l'a entendu
durant ces dernières semaines seule la
proximité est en mesure de garantir
l'indispensable réactivité et
l'impérieuse efficacité de l'action
publique
surtout quand les circonstances rendent
cette action cruciale
voire même vital je voudrais rappeler
aussi et surtout les transferts de
patients en direction des cliniques et
les hôpitaux suisses et allemands qui
ont permis de bien d engranger deux
hôpitaux surchargés et de sauver des
vies ils ont été rendues possibles grâce
aux relations privilégiées que nous
entretenons avec nos collectivités
voisines depuis plusieurs années et elle
prouve bien que nous sommes certes des
partenaires mais nous sommes aussi des
amis je tiens à remercier très
chaleureusement le ministre-président
kretschmann du land de bade wurtemberg
ainsi que les autorités des cantons
suisses voisins et des présidents et les
ministres de la
hantée de bâle-ville de bâle-campagne et
du jura nous avons sans doute posé là
l'une des plus belles pierres
fondatrices du schéma de coopération
transfrontalière dont l'adoption
relèvera de la collectivité en plaine
d'alsace et pour conclure mon propos
j'aimerais partager avec vous un constat
qui est extrêmement rassurant et positif
celui de cette extraordinaire chaîne de
solidarité qui s'est construite au fil
des semaines
oui chers collègues le conseil
départemental a été lors des maillons
essentiels de cette chaîne et ce grâce à
votre mobilisation à tous
à chacune et à chacun d'entre nous je
reconnais et je tiens à vous en
remercier
et grâce à la mobilisation de l'ensemble
de nos collaboratrices et collaborateurs
grand merci à vous grand merci à toutes
et à tous pour cette exceptionnelle
engagement je veux aussi vous faire part
de mes sentiments profonds qui s'est
encore considérablement renforcé en moi
à l'occasion de la crise
ce n'est qu'en laissant les
collectivités locales
agir entreprendre et innover plus
librement que notre pays sera à la
hauteur des véritables défis du 21e
siècle
car ce sont véritablement elles qui
permettent au lieu de conjuguer
proximité réactivité efficacité et
solidaire
ce sont là je le rappelle quelques
heures des principes qui nous ont
conduits chers collègues a créé la
collectivité européenne d'alsace qui va
naître le 1er janvier prochain
donc je crois 252 jours à une nouvelle
collectivité alsacienne dont la
pertinence et dont la cohérence se
révèle aujourd'hui avec encore plus
d'élégance